Pulitzer Prize winner Robert Barkley who
spent 30 years at the helm of the Wall
Street Journal's editorial page died
Wednesday at the age of 66
mr. Bartley was the author of a book on
Reagan economic policy called the seven
fat years in 1992 it was the subject of
his book notes interview the program
lasts an hour Robert L Bartley author of
the seven fat years and how to do it
again what's this book all about well
this book is about the seven fat years
from 1983 to 1990 we had a big economic
boom in this country and it almost
forgotten it by now would you get the
title well the title comes from the book
of Genesis 7 fat years and Joseph being
devour the Pharaoh dreamed about Joseph
interpreted his dream saying now we're
going to have seven fat years followed
by seven lean years and you think that's
what we're going to have well I hope not
I hope that we can that generate a
little optimism witnesses as I partly by
remembering what we did during the seven
fat years I think there is a danger of
seven lean years if we get into Santa's
self-realizing pessimism that's
basically what I'm warning against we've
had lots of books written in the last
couple years and a tremendous number of
them say they were great years but
you're saying they're great years and
you're you make no apology well and we
can do it again that's the main thing is
that there's nothing predestined about
seven lean years we can go out and apply
some of the lessons we learned during
the 80s and create prosperity maybe we
can do it a little better this time I
think there were some mistakes but I
don't think that's what most of the
books have been saying most of the books
have been saying that it was a terrible
time but in fact we grew the economy by
1/3 over these years that I'm writing
about the air we just supposed blend
come went up by 20% we won the Cold War
not a bad record let me ask you a
question that this struck me as I read
this book Bob Bartley is the editor of
The Wall Street Journal has access to
the editorial page that goes into over
close to 2 million homes or people in
the United States why bright a book when
you could have written ticket 7 articles
that appeared day after day in the Wall
Street Journal and get the same point
across well the book of course draws
very heavily on the editorials that I
wrote blank clear back to the middle
1970s but it's a different thing if you
can get it all together in one place
rather than in little snippets day by
day and I hope that it will provide a
record that people can consult if they
want to understand kind of the
continuity of what went on how most of
the Wall Street Journal editorial page
or view had to do with supply-side
economics Oh quite a bit we generally
credited with inventing supply-side
economics or at least spreading word I
like popularizing it really starting
well before Ronald Reagan starting in
the middle 1970s really and as I
explained in the book the terminology
may be a little misleading native none
of us at the time thought that
supply-side economics was something new
on the face of the earth we thought it
was kind of standard pre Keynesian kind
of economics that applied better to the
conditions of the 1970s and 1980s than
the Keynesianism that was being taught
in the Universities at that time we get
back to that but I want to ask you give
a chapter cold man from Mars what's that
all about
well I have this man from Mars a kind of
opening the book I call it the paradox
of the 80s and the man from Mars lands
in Kankakee and starts wandering around
and he looks at all of the parking lots
full of cars shipped all the way from
Japan and he goes into
to record stores that now have music
videos by Madonna and Malay vanilla yet
and the kids have $100 sneakers but
everybody listens to and all the book
titles he reads says that the nation is
declining that we have enormous problems
that we have the S&L for example mutated
into the eggplant that that ate kankakee
Tampa and Los Angeles and he trying to
figure out what's going on here so he
adds a little handheld thattaboy and
starts to Punk into it to get the
statistics for these years and and finds
as I said it kind of be grew by 1/3
every disposable income grew by 1/5 the
whole face of the society was remade
really in 1980 if I recall correctly
have it in the book exactly something
like 2% of the homes had VCRs that whole
industry all those record all those
video shops were all created in the
1980s and particularly after the boom
started in 83 why are people then so
down on the three well I think that the
biggest reason is that rapid progress is
unsettling that I have a chapter in not
talking about the fact that Thomas
Malthus wrote about his very deeply
pessimistic economics just at the odds
outside of the Industrial Revolution
when mankind was making this
tremendously well these leaps of
progress caused rapid change and a rapid
change there are always people who lose
you know some the United Auto Workers
for example lost out lost a lot of jobs
because of the rising Japanese industry
in this case a lot of chief executive
officers lost jobs when their firms were
merged or taken over
and they have to go out and create new
lives for themselves and this is this is
a real problem reaction comes then when
we want to stop all this upset and all
this tumult and all this change and
there's kind of I think a societal
reaction to to slow things down but you
find that when you try to do that then
the whole economy slows down and that I
think is paradox of these these same
thing happened in the 1930s when in a
way a reaction to the 1920s
Michael 1 what is it Oh Michael 1 is a
restaurant with very good porterhouse
steaks down in Wall Street area a few
steps from the American Stock Exchange
and we used to hold seminars there Bob
Mondello who was a economist at Columbia
University and art Laffer of famous now
by the Laffer curve and Jude walinski
was on my staff at The Wall Street
Journal and myself and a few other
people used to gather there for dinner
and talk generally about comics and out
of this came supply-side economics or a
view of the modern economy that I think
explains pretty well what happened as we
resolved economic crisis of the 1970s
and started the 75 years and when did
you start having these seminars Michael
1 I think it was probably in 74 who's
Arthur Laffer Arthur Laffer is a now
consulting economist he was academic
economists at the University of Chicago
and at the University of Southern
California he during this period he
achieved some sort of fame with the the
Laffer curve which said that when taxes
get so high when they get too high they
start to bring in lower revenues rather
than that higher revenues so that yes
there's the Laffer curve
as you see drawn on a napkin that's part
of the lore that it was first drawing on
a napkin at a restaurant here in
Washington booster this restaurant is in
New York or Michael one is in New York
but this this one is the two continents
yeah and the folklore of the Laffer
curve napkin you discuss in your book
that there are several opinions on where
he actually wrote this down yeah what's
that folklore yes that's right well dude
when insky is reported that he drew it
for dick cheney who was done deputy
White House chief of staff in the
conversation of three of them had at the
two continents restaurant unfortunately
neither laugher nor Cheney remembers
this and this has led to some dispute
about where it was originally yet drawn
as I say in the book I believe when in
skiiis he's he's a good journalist and
it's the kind of thing that a journalist
would remember who is jude wanniski
goodwin insky is the fellow that worked
for me during these years he now has his
own firm called pol economics I hired
him it was actually my first hire after
I took over the editorial page of The
Wall Street Journal in 1972 he'd been a
newspaper man in Las Vegas and and
Alaska originally from Brooklyn a very a
billionth character who really got us
all together laugher and Mandel and
myself during these years and then wrote
a book about it modestly called the way
the world works which was one of the
Bible's of the supply-side movement in
the late 1970s and he left the journal
in 78 and struck out in his own and and
you know has met a payroll ever since
you say that he was your second choice
as the number one number to hire ended
she wanted to make when he became editor
in 72 who was the first the first was
George Will
was then an aide to Senator Allen of
Colorado no one knew him very much but I
got to know it know him when I lived in
Washington for a year and he and I was
told at lunch one day that I was going
to take over the editorial page of The
Wall Street Journal in the next morning
I was in George's living room trying to
hire him it didn't work out
probably better for him not so good for
me maybe this is your 20th year as
editor of the editorial or the head of
the Wall Street Journal yeah that title
has changed but I've been running the
editorial page ever since 1972 what's
the title now title is editor and vice
president now there are lots of names
and I the reason I wrote a bunch of them
down because I wanted you to talk about
the impact of people on something like
this we've talked about June Winooski
Arthur Laffer herb Stein what role he
play well herb Stein named supply-side
economics
he's been mostly against it throughout
his career but he named it at at one
resort at one conference talking about
the supply-side fiscal us which he said
included maybe two economists but then
most of the people in the room wanted to
enroll in what he was describing and
when in ski then dropped the fiscal
astern just kept supply-side economics
and that's what it became this is a
small thing but I think I remember you
saying that he he named it at the
homestead in Virginia that's correct
the reason I mentioned that is that last
weekend in the New York Times front page
Sunday lead story Homestead Virginia and
it was a story about trade with third
world countries and how our trade was up
and it quoted a whole bunch of American
businessmen his homestead Virginia in
these places like Michael one where a
lot of this policies developed well the
homestead is a famous resort hotel there
in Virginia that's host to a lot of
different conferences and I presume this
I didn't happen to read that story but I
presume this is a conference
discussed that particular issue I get I
guess what I'm getting at is that you
know you name a lot of people here in
you name a location where you all had
these conversations is that the way
American policies developed I suppose it
is I never really thought about that
very much but I think that that a lot of
it now is being developed in kind of
informal groups and think tanks maybe
less in universities and he actually
used to be the case because we've had
this proliferation of think tanks a very
high-powered places really starting with
Brookings and including AI and heritage
and a whole whole host of others that I
think really do the the policy oriented
kind of thinking these days of much more
than the universities other names Norman
Turei you mentioned him in the Michael
one chapter
Ozzie Norman Norman Turei is an
economist in Washington ran his own
consulting firm in these years and does
again now he was under secretary of the
Treasury under Reagan and force for tax
cuts
he's a very rigorous economist and I
think did the best job of developing the
notion that that if you change tax rates
you change incentives that you have to
look at this from the from what is
called microeconomics that is from the
individual consumer or firm and that
that your management of the macroeconomy
has to be built on firm micro economic
views before I mentioned some more names
if you could do a couple of things right
now that would impact this economy name
them all I would cut the capital gains
tax how far be the first one well as far
as I could I mean I would not be adverse
to eliminating it if I thought that were
politically feasible I
is not if you look across the world most
places have very minimal and some have
none in terms of taxes on capital gains
I mean you the income was taxed when you
first earned it and then if you invest
it you should you be taxed again if you
invest it successfully is the issue what
do you say to those that say it only
helped the rich well I'm not too too
concerned about that I mean you can
debate who the rich are and who who it
helps but I think that my primary
interest is that it helps the people who
want to get rich that is in particular
the entrepreneurs which I think are
absolutely key to the economy these days
and you can retrace the history the
capital gains tax was cut in 1978 and
Styger amendment it was called which I
discuss in the book and very shortly
thereafter it was a great profusion and
in the venture capital industry the
start of a lot of new firms you in the
1980s just an amazing record of firms
started by college dropouts and illegal
immigrants and so on the most notable
other are the software firms in
particular Microsoft which is 1980 was
just a couple of guys when I'm to land a
contract now is maybe the most valuable
piece of industrial property in the
United States after only 12 years can I
interrupt to go back to the 1978 Steiger
man William Steiger Republican from
Wisconsin surround ed who died at age 40
of a heart attack I remember that's
right as of was he a member of the Ways
and Means Committee yes how could a
Republican get an amendment like this
passed well it's quite an amazing thing
that that could happen particularly
since it was passed over the very bitter
opposition of the the Carter White House
I think the answer is the time was ripe
people recognize that that something was
very deeply wrong with the economy and
with the tax policies and he managed to
sell enough Democrats on his idea that
it actually passed but I think there was
an underlying change in the national
mood in 1978 was also the year they of
the proposition 13 in California it was
kind of a gathering mood I think of
which the the Steiger amendment was part
what had prop 13 do in California prop
13 were very severely limited the
property taxes in California and was
passed by Howard Jarvis as a initiative
that is a they petitioned it onto the
ballot and passed it over the objections
of the state's political leaders have
you reviewed the impact of that how many
years later 14 years later whatever I
can't say that I have in any real
careful way but of course California did
have a big boom over most of those 14
years and and now recently they raised
taxes again and our our trebled economy
what else would you do cut the capital
gains tax number two what would you do
well I would I would try to do what I
could to make credit available to to
small businesses I think this has been a
particularly ryo's at the journal we had
a story here the other day about how
loans to small businesses are starting
to pick up and I think that's a very
healthy kind of thing the I notice the
Securities Exchange Commission also has
proposals to encourage these kind of
loans by allowing banks to sell packages
of them the way they do for mortgages I
think that a very constructive proposal
in a way this is kind of reinventing the
junk bond I mean a junk bond was a
marvelous and it's early years at least
a marvelous capital raising device for
for small businesses and from
and provided a lot of the startup
capital for various businesses
well we're on it michael milken well
michael milken I think is a very
complicated character that will take us
some years yet to to digest and come to
some kind of a perspective on I
obviously committed some crimes they can
he he pled guilty to crimes I I think
somewhat gratuitously that he did not
need to get involved and some of these
deals he didn't need to to deal with
Ivan Boesky at the same time he also did
a lot of good for a lot of rising rising
businesses to try and stand he really
was a very creative person then in
financing for for start-up businesses I
think a lot of his problems arose when
junk bonds then became used as a
takeover device against large
corporations and this made him
exceedingly unpopular was very
influential figures in in American
business one of your colleagues although
not in the same section James Stewart
has been here as guest on book notes and
he has a best-selling book den of
thieves would you explain the difference
between where Jim Stewart works in the
Wall Street Journal where you work well
Jim is page one editor very talented
editor page one is part of the news
department I'm in the opinion Department
as editor of The Wall Street Journal I
run editorials the op-ed material
articles on the editorial page the
leisure nartz coverage and art set up
and plus the editorial pages of our two
foreign editions in Hongkong and
Brussels the news department is
is a different Empire a much larger one
but I think not as much fun let me ask
you though about how that works
who runs the editorials not the
editorial opinion side but the front
page the overall that part of the paper
who's in charge who's your equal
Norman pearl Stein the executive editor
and also Paul Steiger the managing
editor are the two to executives who run
the news departments both Norman and I
report you know at the same level we
will basically report to the chairman of
Dow Jones
now let's if Norman Pearlstein has
something he wants on your editorial
page and you don't want it there does it
go there no you know it's Oldham comes
up and exactly that way but you know if
Norman has something he wants on the
editorial page probably there's a reason
for it and I'd be very unlikely to say
no I think what about the reverse of
that what if you want a story written
that you want on the front page well I
did I wouldn't ordinarily do that do
anything about that if I had a story
that I wanted written night public or
write it on my pages rather than
different to him but you know I might
make a suggestion sometime of a story
and then they'll either follow it up or
not but I wouldn't pressure them or get
out of sorts if they didn't see the
story the same way I did
what I'm kind of getting that is on the
James Stewart book where he comes down
hard on Ivan Boesky and Mike Milken and
Denis Levine and others there's a you
know I don't heard that much talk about
some talk about how on your editorial
page you've defended Mike Milken a lot
more than that and was there a
difference of opinion between you and
James Stewart's of the Wall Street
Journal about Mike Milken oh I think so
yes how strong a difference is well I
think in a way it's it's
narrowing some if you if you read the
epilogue to Jim's book I find that well
he thinks that insider trading ought to
be defined in other words there's no
definition of Fisk's crime that's
supposedly so heinous he goes through
the fact that most of the Giuliani
prosecutions were overturned who is
Giuliani
Giuliani was the New York US attorney in
New York who was bringing these insider
trading cases under the RICO law that is
a racketeering law and he got a number
of prosecution a number of one a number
of cases but then they were a long
series of them were overturned by the
appellate judges on one ground or
another of course it didn't help Milken
because he already agreed to plead
guilty and the first of the reversals
happened really shortly after he agreed
to his plea one more question on the
journal if someone reads a front-page
piece or if they read the editorial page
piece or they're looking at two
different philosophies well the front
page would be it certainly could happen
I wouldn't want to suggest that the
front page has only one philosophy I
mean they cover the news and various
kinds of ways but you could certainly
certainly have been instances in which
you have different views on the
editorial page and the and the page one
or the Washington page this basically
reflects the fact that we on the
editorial page do our own reporting and
that means we have a set of sources and
the news men report in may have
different set of sources and really in
that kind of position you have no
alternative but to go with your own go
with your own sources so you
yet differences arising in that way I
don't think that it may be a little
unseemly sometimes but I don't think the
reader suffers is he gets the
perspective again you have what three
pages the editorial page the op-ed page
and the Arts and Leisure gets right six
back to the restaurant
Michael one another name that comes up
in the context of that is Lou Lehrman
and Paul Craig Roberts who was Lou
Lehrman and why is his name coming well
Lou Lehrman was a very successful
executive with Rite Aid Corporation who
then retired after he and his colleagues
had built the corporation came to New
York set set up the lurmen Institute
which is kind of another public policy
pen shop ran that for a number of years
of which we'd have little seminars and
in the afternoon on both foreign policy
and economic policy then after a point
Lou ran for governor of New York lost by
a couple hundred thousand votes to Mario
Cuomo
where is he today well he's back in the
think tank business today as well as I
think being a very highly successful
investor Craig Roberts was a Capitol
Hill staffer a PhD economist worked for
Kemp for a while actually wrote the camp
Roth tax cut bill or at least was the if
you have to name a single author of it
at the staff level that would certainly
be Craig now when when insky left I
hired Craig for a year comp New York and
and I kind of keep the ball rolling a
column for for us at the journal wrote
some editorials then
I came back to Washington and then was
hired into the Reagan administration as
assistant secretary of the Treasury very
powerful force for these ideas
he's now again in the think tank
business here in Washington University
of Chicago well the University of
Chicago Department of Economics has been
kind of a traditional home of classical
economists economics all through the
Keynesian era had a number of very
distinguished professors the most
notable in our lifetime has been Milton
Friedman and Milton Friedman basically
carried the classical economics idea of
course he's also a very skillful
advocate and with him and with that
tradition
it's gathered together a lot of very you
know ardent free-market types and it's
Department of Economics in to some
extent and its Business School laugher
in Mandel are both there at different
stages of their careers is how do you
characterize Milton Freeman today in
your eyes as he you know is he a guru of
this of supply-side he cannot economist
well Milton is in kind of a curious
position in many ways he is he would
agree with us about nine out of ten
things whatever we I have a little
section in there quoting some Bank
economist saying I used to be a
monetarist I think that and says I used
to be a monikers but I've kind of come
with the conclusion that the this kind
of money supply
isn't kind of a be-all and end-all of
economics the second thing that Milton
would disagree with myself and my
friends about is he's still an ardent
proponent of floating exchange rates
that's something I think we'd be better
off to get rid of if we get back to
something like the Bretton Woods
international monetary system those
things we disagree about we would agree
that government spending is the kind of
best measure of the government's impact
on the economy rather than for example
the deficit we would agree that it's
much better to let the markets work that
it's not too good an idea for the for
the federal government to try and you
know fine tune the economy at jiggle it
around this way of that those very
important things we would be a guru or a
sympathizer of this group but he has his
own particular velocity that he has his
own personal stamp on that is a little
different from where we are let me go
back to some number of things you said
and maybe quick definitions would help
us
what is a monetarist poll monitors
basically is a follower of milton
friedman but for us they they they
emphasize the very importance of what we
call the money supply like which one mm
1 M 2 etc which is under the control
more or less of the Federal Reserve
System in other words the Federal
Reserve can can control at least bank
reserves and then those bank reserves
kind of are loaned out and become M 1 or
M 2 what are you talking about when you
said Bretton Woods
well Bretton Woods as a Resort Hotel in
New Hampshire
where
in 1944 and the Allied powers negotiated
a international monetary arrangement
that is they said okay when the war is
over we're going to have to get the
world economy straightened out and they
came up with some arrangements on
exchange rates they created the World
Bank and the International Monetary Fund
at the same time they're not at Bretton
Woods I don't think but in conjunction
with that you had the general agreement
on tariffs and trade to cut tariffs
around the world and this GATT that's
got yeah this arrangement with opening
in the world markets and stable exchange
rates basically pegged to the dollar
which then had a relationship to gold
led to an amazing time in the world
economy there was really a golden era
between all about 1950 when all of these
arrangements were in place and 1973 you
can see things kind of break in 73 and
that period from fifty to seventy three
is was really the greatest growth period
of the century both in the industrial
economies and in the developing
economies by the way taking off your
book the seven fat years seven that 83
and ninety yes how do these years how
important are these years in history
well they're awfully important in
history in terms of the geopolitics I
mean this is when the Cold War was over
and I think that that if we handle
things right now we may be entering a
entirely new era and we've had a pretty
ghastly century with two world wars and
the Great Depression and
people and then followed by the cold war
and I hope that that the
breaching of the Berlin Wall and
nineteen eighty nine may assure in an
entirely new and much more hopeful Iraq
we also have we also have enormous
technological progress going on at the
moment I call it the Second Industrial
Revolution we've had the atomic energy
we've had the splitting of the gene
we've had probably most important the
invention of the transistor and now the
microchip but it's changing the entire
texture of the economy from an
industrial economy and doing the
information economy this should be very
good for us and between the between the
Second Industrial Revolution in the end
of this world war confrontation
should allow us if we kind of get things
right to construct a much more hopeful
era than we have grown up there back to
Michael one how often did you have
dinner there oh I don't know that I
could count the times and maybe it
doesn't I don't know so let me he didn't
go to every we going on no there wasn't
any regular schedule to it and but of
course the way Michael one is is a
symbol even if we wanted Michael one
these discussions were about these ideas
or we're almost constant they would be
around my desk at the at the journal
they would be by phone with with laugher
and Mundel and later with with Turay and
Roberts in Washington so that there was
an awful lot of intellectual ferment I
wouldn't want to create the ideas only
happened at Michael one well I just
mentioned that because that you put a
chapter to it but I wanted wanted to
find out what happened as Michael one is
a symbol what happened with the
information that you all developed would
you do with it or a lot of of course we
published in the Wall Street Journal
editorials or op-ed pieces well I think
probably more op-ed pieces than than
editorials although he had editorials -
under whose name under really a great
variety of people's names I mean when
insky wrote some notable ones but what
we found was once we started to run some
of these ideas authors who shared them
and have started coming out of the
woodwork and we'd get the submissions
from people in Atlanta or San Francisco
that fit as part of the framework and we
would run those and I think that's one
reason I think that the this is not
something that we dreamed up all by
ourselves it was part of the temper of
the time and the idea is that a lot of
people were kind of thinking along the
same lines and once an outlet for these
ideas was created it became a kind of
self generating process are you still in
touch with all those people yes indeed
there's one name I haven't mentioned
that kept coming up throughout the book
and that's Jack Kemp
what role does he play and it's your
candidate for president well I think
he'd make a good one you know it's I
mean we got enough candidates for
president this year I guess but at some
point in his career I'd certainly would
I would look enthusiastically on that he
might not be the only candidate that I
would be willing to back
enthusiastically but Jack of course was
was instrumental in in the political
side of this he's the fellow picked up
on these ideas who was the driving force
behind the Kimbrough bill that then
ultimately became the Reagan 1981 tax
cuts and he's still at it today he said
something earlier I want you to find
also that rather than looking at the
deficit people all look at the
percentage of government expense as it
relates to the GNP yes why I think
that well I think that's the best single
measure what's GNP GNP is is the total
output of the economy
I guess these days now we've switched to
gross domestic product and what eating
that whether you can you give us a
finger on roughly what that is is it
five trillion yeah something in that
neighborhood I I'm not real good at
remembering specific figures so if we
have one point two trillion and in
government expenditures that's what
twenty percent of the GDP well the
government the government expenditures
are now running around twenty four
twenty five percent of GNP I had a chart
in the book expenditure tax receipts are
running around 19 maybe 20 percent the
interesting thing about this chart is
that the receipts are really pretty
stable going back clear to 1950 they're
[Music]
20% 21% might be a record low might be
17% it's a very narrow band the
expenditures on the other hand took off
and studying really in 1974 and the
difference of course is is the deficit
how high is that percentage been GNP the
expenditure part expenditure part about
25 that's federal
they would then state and local spending
would be in addition when do you get
nervous well I get nervous at 25 for
everything or just the feds know for the
for the Fed I think so you're
comfortable at 24 well I would like to I
would like to see it well I think it's a
trimmed more than anything else is
that's disturbing I mean the trend is
more each year and as you take more each
year it means you're taking a larger and
larger share of the new money in the
economy and at some point that becomes a
disincentive to to production
disincentive in the private sector and
the general economy starts to slow down
I think that that's a much the the
rationale for looking at expenses rather
than at the deficit is that is it the
expenses are the amount of money that
the government is taking out of the
private sector now whether it takes
those by taxes or by borrowing them is
kind of a secondary matter that the
primary matter is how much money is it
taking that's measured by expenditures
we take your temperature on three men
George Bush on one at a time okay George
Bush I would have been happier if Bush
had been a little more Reagan ask a
little more like Ronald Reagan I think
ultimately however the records still out
the revocation of his no new taxes
pledge I think hurt him both politically
and economically
I think the 1990 budget deal raising
taxes once you're already in a recession
is a very bad mistake on the other hand
I'm not sure how much choice he had at
that time because it also came just as
he was building support for his war in
Iraq which I support so he may not have
been in a position to have a
confrontation or with Congress over the
budget just at that time so you keep him
forgive him that a little bit I think if
he has a second term you're likely to
have a different Congress and he might
be more successful
because of that will he be back I
suspect so Bill Clinton and I don't have
any real strong opinions about Bill
Clinton I don't think you know he's a
menace I'm not sure that he really
believes in anything no he's just such a
his whole life has been as a politician
that you know he's so that if he takes a
position the kind of starting assumption
is that well he's taking that for some
political reason not because he actually
believes in it Ross Perot on Ross Perot
I don't know what he believes that
either he hasn't keep silence he's going
to do these wonderful things as
president but he doesn't he doesn't tell
us what they are I think unless he could
get that straightened out his candidacy
may be in some difficulty there's a
journal ever endorsed the journal I
think so far as I know the journal has
has endorsed one presidential candidate
and it's 100 and some year history that
was Herbert Hoover and I think maybe we
learned our lesson and so we don't
formally endorse now we we are pretty
outspoken in our editorials and you will
won't where we stand in any particular
election I sometimes we may have
stronger opinions and others but you
will find that if you know if you read
us you you'll find what we think about
the men and the issues but we don't
typically write editorials saying well
we endorsed so-and-so and because we
endorsed them you should vote for them
and we think that's a little bit of
empty exercise how many people work for
you on the editorial board well my
budget staff is I think 35 people at the
moment
this includes the people abroad includes
the legion arts people includes the
clerical people so that if you ask how
many people are actually contributing
editorials the kind of the question
becomes where do you draw the line we
don't have too many people who do that
full-time we have people like Paul Gigot
in Washington and Tim Ferguson and Los
Angeles and George Malone and Brussels
who write columns and write one column
we Plus they write editorials the
principal force behind the editorials
putting them together every day now is
my deputy editor the editorial page
daniel heininger and then we have a
couple of other people who write
editorials or full-time and then we have
a variety of people including some of
the leisure and arts people who
contribute one now and then how often do
you actually sit down and write a full
editorial first of all probably in this
last little while every other week or so
I have also been written some byline
columns very recently though and what do
you most likely to feel the strongest
about well I have been writing some
economic editorials here because that's
what we have needed I also wrote about
the Los Angeles Riots one of our two
long editorials on that I am sure that
as the presidential campaign heats up
I'll have some editorials about politics
I have a way of picking off the
breakfast topics and they're the ones
that usually get me moving in for a
moment let's suggest that there's a 20
year old out there watching who's always
wanted to write for The Wall Street
Journal what's the best possible
training to work for you at The Wall
Street Journal
well the best possible training for
writing is writing that's what Hemingway
said the way you write is too
plenty the seat of your pants to the
seat of the chair and right and the way
you way you become journalists is to get
something published whether it's in a
campus publication or whatever and that
is when we sit on to hire someone and
you're in the infrequent occasions in
which we actually have openings what
counts are the clips other words what
they've published elsewhere that they
can send along with their letter that's
by far the overwhelming factor in hiring
decisions in the last 20 years how often
have you had an opening well had that's
kind of a specific fact we all mean well
we are likely to have an opening of the
professional level every other year
something on that neighborhood that
would include editors as well as writers
your background hometown and university
in subjects you study well I was born in
Marshall Minnesota grew up basically in
Ames Iowa went to Iowa State University
there worked for a year at the Grinnell
Iowa Herald Register which comes out
twice a week at opportunity while I was
there to hone my skills of the
photographer as well as as well as a
writer I took a master's degree in
political science at the University of
Wisconsin my undergraduate major at Iowa
State had been journalism and I was
hired on to the Chicago beer over The
Wall Street Journal in 1962 as a report
as a reporter and I was 2 years as a
reporter and 64 I came onto the
editorial page in New York this book
number one for you have you written
other Sol yes no no no this is this is
the first book that I've written to my
father and the memory of my mother they
arranged their lives so that I might do
this how long do you think that out
that's your dedication yeah well I
didn't take very long I think how did
they arrange their lives to help they
made sure I got a good education and
they went to some effort I think to do
that father allow your mother dead yes
that's right where does my father still
a Nile what did he do for a living he
was a veterinarian and while they was
names a professor of veterinary medicine
at the university there and how did they
influence you in those early years well
there hey I guess made me a serious
young man traditional discipline and
support and they encouraged me to you
know they got made into the aims public
schools which were and I have every
reason to believe still are quite
remarkable schools because it's a
university town and most of the children
great percentage of the children have
from faculty families and really a very
very intellectual kind of place and at
the same time a kind of down-to-earth
Midwestern at a place and marvelous
education home of Isles - yes that's
right the engineering and agriculture
college here in the book you mentioned a
couple of other people that economists
by the name of say John baptise say yes
who was he well he's a very notable
classical economist I don't know why
right now you know from a couple
centuries ago or a century ago it was
after Adam Smith but 1767 to 1835 I
thought you might have it there but he
he formed what's called says-- law which
was kind of the bedrock proposition of
classical economics and say his law is
that production creates its own demand
in other words that the economy is a
cyclical kind of process that if you
produce something you pay money as I
explained it in there the
you know widget makers pay the their
employees to make the widgets and the
employees use their compensation to buy
widgets and and if you extend this over
an economy and over a great number of
great variety of goods you have a
picture of an economy when were you
first introduced him not in person but I
mean well I remember art Laffer saying
during these discussions I don't know
what it was at Michael 1 or whether it
was in my office but he's saying that
you know you got to learn about say
healing but saves laughts is what I
believe in it's what you believe in - of
course then I didn't know what it was
there's another name I'm sure I'll
mispronounce it hey ik Hayek yeah Hayek
who was he well he is a very famous
Austrian economist who died here this
year is a very elderly man he was a
contemporary and a critic of Keynes and
then he was more or less forgotten for a
great many years until well he was more
or less forgotten is not quite correct
because he wrote a very famous book
called the road for a road to serfdom
but he wasn't viewed as kind of in the
forefront of modern economics during the
Keynesian era and but I think that
keynesian ism kind of collapsed during
the 1970s when you had this simultaneous
inflation and and unemployment that the
Keynesian formulation doesn't even allow
I can't explain it well and this
perception I think gradually spread
around the world and lo and behold very
lateness life then Hayek was given a
Nobel Prize for economics and we better
define who John Maynard Keynes's was
well John Maynard Keynes was the the
most influential economist of this
century British wrote
during before and during the Depression
and Great Britain his most famous book
is called the general theory and it
really established a view of economics
for two generations it published in the
30s and was really dominant until the
seventies and whole structures of
economical structures of thought were
built around Kings general theory I and
most of the people of Michael won their
admirers of Keynes as a person but we
think his and his theories may have been
relevant and needed during the Great
Depression but they didn't apply very
well to the 1970s
there is in the book of our Veloz quote
from Hayek who said that toward the end
of Keynes life he was very worried that
his theories might be misused
particularly as an engine for inflation
but he told how I could well don't worry
about it because if that ever starts to
get out of hand I can turn it around
overnight two weeks later Keynes was
dead and couldn't turn it around and I
actually know what have to will have to
be explained by history is how a whole
generation of economists kind of woke up
bewildered because they couldn't
understand things that had been fairly
widely understood before the Keynesian
revolution knowing what you know and
think about every day do you often it's
a leading question but do you ever sit
and watch the political discussion and
listen to people out in the country talk
back and say if they really knew what
they were talking about they'd never say
that well you have occasions of that of
course but you know I'm kind of a
populist I believe that that the common
people out there in the country are
really pretty smart they may not be able
to tell you about
and Hayek and all that but they they
have a kind of a street sense of what's
working and what isn't out in the street
and I think that when you get something
like the kind of change in the mood that
I was talking about in 1978 that often
the common people in the street at our
head the policy makers and the big
thinkers that's what the book looks like
it's by Robert L Bartley the editor of
The Wall Street Journal it's called the
seven fat years and how to do it again
thank you for joining us thank you very
much Brian
on December 3rd
Robert Berkeley was awarded the
Presidential Medal of Freedom the
nation's highest civilian honor
he died Wednesday at the age of 66
[Music]